what's up Greg Alba cheer what it do
John Humphrey I'm Perry Nemiroff yeah
Terry Nemiroff just came back from Star
Wars Celebration she literally just flew
in and drove right here in the next wing
that is that wasn't alive
if you don't know Perry I don't know why
you don't know Perry but Perry is pretty
popular she's not Collider videos
she is P never off on Twitter and
Instagram and holy [ __ ] she she's a TV
fights winner right now to keep you face
myself like that
hey Perry have you ever seen a romantic
comedy I would say I've seen quite a few
okay Perry have you seen the Silence of
the Lambs that is a big no on that one
you haven't seen so what are we going to
say time to the land as a romantic
comedy we're missing some people and
acting may teach you to listen and
respond correctly this is this is why
I'm not an actor of my wife I'm not in a
fix
bombshell I'm just going for it guys do
it don't mine
good job FBI agent gets tremor and stuff
fantastic
you know we get a lot of detectives here
but I must say I can't graduate
t be a doctor in time
Zoe Starling wants nothing more than to
make it at the FBI so far turning heads
is easier than getting ahead jobs come
up I thought about you not a job really
more of an interesting errand sending a
psychiatrist Hannibal Lecter now her new
was done of it might be biting off more
than she could chew
it's very clever easy new pretty young
woman dr. Lecter my name is Clarice
Starling I speak with you Eugene came to
me we didn't think there can be cheap
shoes you looking with me perhaps you
care to lend us your view in this
question you do all these wrong stuff
all that detail just from memory sir
memory agent study is what I have
instead of you know me how about this
tape kidding me
you're doing this coming and coming into
my hospital and ducking into view
refusing to share information with me
for the third time people will say that
ah maybe you can decide for yourself
whether or not I'm qualified enough to
do that
just do your job will ever forget what
he is and what is that get confident out
in your career isn't he apparently he
likes you and you like him too I never
thought about your first lie to me
Carrie
Jodi for me and Anthony he'll come on in
the most romantic movie of the year
our Larry your problem is need get more
fun otherwise the sons of the land doing
this like a clue from a real murder case
cool
ignoring it nothing Wow fix man are you
to watch more of their stuff I like that
I have all trailer you get one too
they also how they have like the best
list we clatter doesn't do list videos
right not really
all right Synnex that's the best list
their list videos will be like 15
greatest opening shots of all time like
they do crazy detail ever this video
feels like a film school episode in same
way oh yeah so not only really funny his
[ __ ] but they also do these awesome list
videos it's incredible what a little
change in music will do yeah and I
detect it and some voiceover but they
did is they pulled it off look like a
weird 90s rom-com yeah this is one of
the maybe one of the most seamless I've
seen these workouts the least amount of
like other kind of trying this one was
like a lot of moments that led me out of
the romantic comedy parody there's bad
ones in the next so I mean not
necessarily from them but just like
every now and I mean you'll see or we
have trailer
summer benefit everybody wants to mash
up or recut a trail yeah is even the
whole trailer when it said whenever I
hear the silence of the lambs a very
specific like feeling that kind of goes
along with that title but when they took
the size of the lamb tear like yeah that
sounds like a romantic comedies like
obtusely titled one yeah yeah that would
would it start like Hugh Grant in an
alternate universe I don't remember it
all that died as much dialogue back I
watch the movie twice when I was
wait-wait younger when I saw them aside
so I the only thought I remember exactly
where and with who I thought Silence of
the Lambs for the first time oh yeah
yeah it was an exploit I know it was
with a group of friends when I must have
been in middle school so probably like
10 or 11 and I just remember we watched
Silence of the Lambs and it was the folk
god no I'm not gonna tell the story it's
inappropriate extra didn't have oh okay
I must have been a little older 10 or 11
might be too young because I remember we
like hid in her bathroom and we cracked
open our first beer ever in our lives
I just remember the specific friend it
was not 10 or 11 that's way too young
don't always show you oh boy am i
turning really red now I hope my mom's
good if there's any 10 or 11 year-olds
out there that was a lie you must be
much older yeah where can they say is
Wow is really pleased for me with little
Buffalo Bill oh yeah didn't use that
stuff yeah a little bit I learned I
learned most of my dirty talking Buffalo
Bill that's disturbing about three lines
as always it doesn't take much it
doesn't take much and it usually doesn't
work in the end you know you follow
somebody you deliver them a letter yes
yeah hello delicious
that's professional winning combination
right there will you ever do that to
someone out there I will be following
with a video camera actually when I was
like set 17 or 18 there were these
people driving up and I knew them they
were driving up a hill and I was at the
top of this in this house this was in my
house I mean two off tangent here
but anyway I did the whole like tuck it
in thing and then out in the middle of
the street just freak these girls out
never got anywhere with em how long the
lesson that what it would want to get
woman you shouldn't do that I would like
there yeah I don't think you were
because now just me and Brandon after
day why we very it's real two years ago
20 years old things we need to hold
pretty awkward stories now so I'm pretty
sure this video is going to be a
high-speed ever right uh I don't think
that's seen the way YouTube is anyway
yeah guy hey hey subscribe it's in
effects please do yourself a favor and
subscribe it's in a fix and you know
what else you should do subscribe to the
real region to the terminal guys yeah
that's good
baby I didn't have Emily throw like an
hour ago and windows we go ahead
John's reasons to Jerry on a Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of blunt
house and the real rejects and Perry
Nemiroff is on Collider video and and
she is awesome she is intelligent she
knows her movies she's like a real penny
night I can't handle hell you know what
else is like the real I'm too many likes
female presence on the YouTube movie
community I feel I think like people
like Brianne or hit or miss movies and
people like you and Wendy are like yeah
you guys are gonna start a revolution
and yeah yeah follow her on a peen
hammer off on Twitter and Instagram
there you happy with your promote okay
yeah